The following content is provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at ocw.mit.edu.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: I think it's a nice topic
to end this semester, because in a way, it
brings together, I think, some of the main
threads that we've through this semester.
But also, in fact, the last point of the text,
alliteration I can sense my point to wait
into the future.
So without further ado, we have Lorraine,
Will, and Cynthia.
GUEST SPEAKER: So this is our presentation
on language resistance and liberation.
Welcome to the last day of class.
Congratulations (CHUCKLING) for getting this
far.
So as the road map, we're going to go through
first "Rethinking Literacy, A Dialogue," the
piece by Freire and Macedo.
Macedo?
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Freire and Macedo.
GUEST SPEAKER: Macedo?
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Macedo.
GUEST SPEAKER: Macedo.
And then we're going to look at the "Literacy
and Critical Pedagogy" piece, and then end
with the MIT Haiti initiatives.
GUEST SPEAKER: OK.
So this is just a little bit of a background
on the writers of the first two pieces.
Both of them are educators in critical pedagogy.
And one is from Brazil, and one is Cape Verdean-American.
GUEST SPEAKER: So in the first piece, Freire
mentions the premise-- the main premises of
culture, and I think that these are really
important to keep in mind, because this is
a really interesting and, I think, powerful
way to frame culture.
The first one is that cultural processes are
intimately connected with social relations,
especially with class relations and class
formations, with sexual divisions, with racial
structuring of social relations, and with
age oppressions as a form of dependency.
Got it? [chuckling]
OK. The second one, culture involves power and
helps to produce asymmetries in the abilities
of individuals and social groups to define
and realize their needs.
And third one, culture is neither autonomous
nor an externally determined field, but a
site of social difficulties and struggles.
Those ideas are really important to keep in
mind, because this paper also raises the idea--
I know it is a social field, which is kind
of the combination of all of the beliefs,
myths, aspirations, hopes of a part of a society,
of a culture, and so it includes things such
as why racial hierarchies exist, to why sexual
divisions exist, and like what roles gender
people play in a society.
And it's really important to keep that in
mind, because if you're able to keep that
in mind, then you're able to think critically
about that.
And through the critical process of engaging
with it, you're able to change the social field.
And so I think that that's important, because
even though this paper raises a lot of really
powerful ideas, it's still not perfect.
So one of the quotes of this paper is, "Literacy's
oral dimension is important, even if it takes
place in a culture, like that of the United
States, whose memory is predominantly written,
not oral, like that of Africa."
Africa is not (LAUGHING) country.
And so something like that is also part of the
social field, and would make it into this paper.
Because even though Freire and Macedo are
thinking critically about this, they are not
engaging with the full reality of cultural
objectivity and being subjects within that.
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah.
So in the next article, Paulo Freire talks
about the use of language as a form of resistance.
And he first starts talking about how the
current traditional methods in literacy how
they tend to ignore the importance of language
in a person's education.
And he bases a lot of his theories on his
experiences.
And from the second quote he says that, "The
sad reality is that while education in Portuguese
provides access to positions of political
and economic power for the higher echelon
of African society, it screens out the majority
of the masses, who fail to learn Portuguese
well enough to acquire the necessary literacy
skills for social, economic, and political
advancement."
And you definitely-- from the way that he
mentions this, you could definitely see a
lot of like correlations between what's going
on around the world and currently in the United
States.
And you could definitely see that the 1% usually
have the most control over things, and that
they usually tends to drive how policies are
made.
But the fact is that when a person is taught
in their native language, they tend to learn
things better and comprehend things faster.
And can we go to the next slide?
There's usually backlash when it comes to
different languages taught in schools.
For example, in the US, people say that students
should learn how to speak standard American
English.
But when it comes to providing these sort
of opportunities to minority groups of, I
guess for instance, like students of color,
there is usually some racial tensions that
develop that make minority students feel inferior.
For example, there was an article mentioned
of like recently, like March of 2017, that
talked about a robotics team that recently
had won the challenge, and the fact that after
they had won the students-- or I guess people
in the crowd started screaming at them and
telling them to go back to Mexico.
And so this form of like demeaning commentary
tends to drive the dropout rates of minority
groups, and all of this tends to contribute
to like the prison-- sorry, the school to
prison pipeline.
As you can see in the infographic, it gives
a lot of percentages talking about this sort
of issue.
You can see in the bottom, it says that 68%
of all males in state and federal prison they
do not have a high school diploma.
And this tends to be-- gives statistics on
students.
And all of this tends to stem from the fact
that minority students do not have the same
access to education as the elite part of society.
And from personal experience, I can definitely
relate to this.
I went to a school about like an hour and
a half from my house, and I definitely did
have a lot of good role models growing up.
But were definitely students around my neighborhood
that didn't have the same access to the same
opportunities that I did.
Some of them did drop out to start working.
Others were influenced by gangs around my
neighborhood.
And you could definitely-- things are definitely
getting better, but things could definitely
be improved from an emancipatory literacy
approach, which is what Paulo Freire mentions.
Yeah.
So in emancipatory literacy, this involves
using the language of the people, rather than
the elites.
It teaches students to accept their experiences
and their culture.
And this moves from the world of objectivity
to the world of subjectivity, where individuals
learn to accept themselves for who they are,
rather than feel like they're a victim of
society.
And Paulo Freire does mention that achieving
emancipatory literacy is hard, but it's not
impossible.
And now I'll-- and so Lorraine wants to talk
about a few examples of how this is being
used today.
So considering specifically the case of Haiti--
which Michel works a lot on, the MIT Haiti
initiative-- virtually all of the schooling
in both K through 12 education and then in
higher education is done in French, and not
in Kreyol.
But the problem is that most people only speak
Kreyol fluently, so like 95% or so, and very
few people speak French fluently, at all.
So when you go through school, and everything
is in a language that you don't understand,
how are you supposed to be able to actually
get any of the education, get any of this
social engagement, especially if children
are punished for speaking Kreyol in school.
And they can't interact with each other, can't
ask questions, can't gather any of the information
that's coming at them.
So it's based on this false belief and really
outdated belief about the hierarchy of languages,
about which languages are created or are younger,
or anything like that, and that Kreyol isn't
developed enough to be able to be used for
technical language for STEM education to have
anything translated into Kreyol.
And part of that is saying that like Kreyol
isn't widespread enough, even though Kreyol
has almost 10 million speakers.
Finnish has only about 5.5 million speakers,
and yet in Finland all of that education is
done in Finnish.
And people have-- studies have found that,
in Finland, kids are much better equipped
to be able to learn a second language, and
to go into higher education and gather all
of these like technical studies, because all
of their education is done in Finnish.
And over at IAP, I was doing MISTI GTL in
the Catalonia region, in Spain, and there
Catalan also has a little under 10 million
speakers.
But in Catalonia all of the education is in
Catalan, which made it difficult for me as
like a "Spanish speaker"-- like not even fluent,
but trying to speak Spanish speaker-- to be
able to teach the students.
But they had such a better experience with
all of their textbooks in Catalan all of their
computer software.
So I was trying to teach them Inkscape and
Gimp, but everything was is (CHUCKLING) Catalan,
and I just couldn't understand like even how
to open a window.
So they taught me a lot about this.
And they-- all of them speak Catalan, and
Spanish, and English, and then they can like
learn German or French on the side, as well.
So all of them, because their initial education
K through 12 and then higher education, if
they want it to be, is in Catalan, then they
can learn all of these other things just as
well as we do like in English, which is mostly
our one and kind of only language in the United
States.
Yeah.
So that was my experience.
And what-- a school that is like a really
good model in Haiti is the LKM School.
I didn't know how to pronounce it in Kreyol,
so it's LKM.
It's a K through 10 school in a rural part
on an island of Haiti, and their education
is starting to be in this model of all Kreyol
education, trying to teach all of these subjects,
all of the technical terms in Kreyol.
And the students are learning much better
than the rest of the students in Haiti, who's
schooling is French and who only 10% graduate
from high school.
So the linguistic apartheid part of this is
that, when you teach somebody in a language
they don't understand, you prevent them from
being able to move into different socioeconomic
classes to attain the education and the success
that they should be able to.
And this all leads to the MIT Haiti initiative
that Michel started here between MIT and all
the Haitian education systems.
So a couple of their main points are to teach
educators in Haiti that teaching in Kreyol
is perfectly fine, that it is actually better
for the students, that it gives them more
opportunities, and that STEM and technical
subjects can be taught in Kreyol.
So a lot of the worries or concerns are that
like Kreyol doesn't have words for these languages.
We didn't have words for a computer either
up until when they were created.
A lot of other languages borrow words from
other languages.
So I learned Japanese, and in Japanese there's
this lovely thing called Katakana
where you just grab words from other languages.
So if you don't know how to pronounce it,
you kind of like make it sound like it, and
oftentimes, it is what has been borrowed.
So for example, bread is pan, from German.
And all of these other languages have words
borrowed from other languages, and that's
what globalization does.
So the same thing should be able to happen
with Kreyol and STEM learning.
And the really good results of this are that
they affirm students' cultures and backgrounds,
and their own upbringings, and how the society
actually works, as opposed to a colonial oppressive
society.
And it equalizes students being able to have
more social mobility, and to attain what they
want and what they should be able to.
GUEST SPEAKER: So to kind of tie this back
to what we can do to stay woke, with regards
to literacy, I think it's important to remember
that, "language is a mediating force of knowledge,
but it is also knowledge itself."
And so one approach is for groups to kind
of come together and create a language that
describes their experience amongst themselves,
and then to share that language and to share
that experience in their own language.
And I think that that is one way that we can
start breaking away from the kind of putting
standard English on a pedestal, and can also
kind of validate other discourses, and other
ways of being, and of other just languages
that kind of already exist in the US and across
the world.
Questions?
How have our understandings of literacy evolved
in response to the internet, unprecedented
global integration, and increased pressure
to preserve human rights?
For example, what does it mean that schools
repress the development of subjectivity, but
do largely ensure literacy?
How can modern notions of literacy evolve
to address the phenomena, such as the proliferation
of fake news?
So if we're moving past literacy as just the
idea of being able to read, and we are entering
this new kind of this new wave being defiantly
pushed by the internet and the influence of
technology on the way we live, literacy is
coming to be a more critical approach to life
in the sense that fake news is a thing, you
know, and it's actually quite hard to distinguish
what news is really what news is fake.
And the ability to do that, having that critical
lens, is maybe the next evolution of literacy.
So any ideas on that, I guess, is the question.
AUDIENCE: So I'm just gonna answer the first
part of this, because I'm not sure if I have
an answer for the next two.
But something that I think is kind of hilarious
about like the integration of the internet
is that I think it's simultaneously making
us more literate and less literate.
So like-- or like pressuring you to be more
literate.
So "pressuring" you to be more literate is
like, now there's a bunch of sources that
you can read, and like now you can be more
educated, it's all open to the public if you
have a computer.
And then there's also like the pressure to
speak English properly, based off either,
you know, like there's one viral video, this
old grandma screaming at this Hispanic woman
in IHOP because she was paying in Spanish,
or something like that.
So like it puts pressure on you to speak English
correctly, and then meanwhile, because of
like things like Facebook and like any social
media, people like don't speak English correctly,
like typing, you know, abbreviations and stuff
that's acceptable in text, but like meanwhile
we're saying you should speak English properly.
So it's kind of a weird dichotomy.
GUEST SPEAKER: I'm interested in the age implications
of what you just said, kind of aligning--
kind of a critique towards the use of different
varieties of English with older generations
and the use of nonstandard varieties of English
with younger generations.
I'm interested in that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think-- I mean, I guess
like-- so like there's a grandma that I know
that's on Facebook, and like she makes sure
to type everything out, including punctuation.
And like her Facebook posts are longer and
they're more like here's a card, that type
of thing.
Whereas like my Facebook, A, I'm just sharing
things, but B, if I write anything, it's probably
not good, proper English.
So I think it does depend on your age group,
but also like going back to the original point
of, you know, that grandma screaming at the
Hispanic woman in IHOP, like it's not just
like an older woman screaming because, you
know, she's more literate.
Like there's also like kids who think like,
oh, you have to speak English in here.
So like there is still that weirdness between
like how older people act on Facebook, and
stuff like that.
But I still think like the point of, you know,
pressuring people is regardless of age.
AUDIENCE: I think because we're gonna be talking
about language, which is dialect in this class,
I would kind of risk saying that we're kind
of creating a new language because of the
internet with like all the abbreviations and
things.
And there's the way-- the push for speed and
everything like that.
So I think the reason that older generations
don't use it as much is because they're not
used to it, and they're in a different frame
of reference and they just haven't learned
this new dialect that we're starting to use.
So I think that it's a good thing, in a sense,
but a lot of people who want that standard
American English are going to be pushing us
to go back to that, as opposed to using the
internet language.
But going as far as our changes in literacy
because of the internet, like I didn't know
that The Onion was satire, at first.
Well, I just didn't know that The Onion existed.
And then when I saw that, I realized that
that was satire.
I think that nuance like that is something
that you miss especially with the internet,
because you can't really express sarcasm very
clearly over just plain text.
And I think that's something that we're like
struggling with, because of the internet.
AUDIENCE: But I think that you said-- you
talked about The Onion.
I think that shows like Stephen Colbert or
the Colbert Report, and shows like that, show
that we have been dealing with that sort of
satire language issue.
Because for a long time, people [inaudible] the
Colbert Report didn't realize that it was satire.
So I think that we've done this before, and
it's sort of a different cycle.
But now it's on the net instead of being TV.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to bounce off what you
originally said.
Like with like it's not a bad thing that we're
checking the language, I agree with this
It's kind of like [inaudible], as you mentioned.
Do you think like there are certain rules,
like the way we type, and like is there like
a way to be literate like with our new abbreviations?
AUDIENCE: I think there definitely is.
Like for instance, punctuating sentences with
like LOL or ha ha.
Like the beginning of the end, where you put
that.
Using emojis to get more emotion in it.
Like there's definitely like a science to
it that we kind of fell into, but didn't realize
was [inaudible].
AUDIENCE: Yeah. OK, cool. This is interesting.
GUEST SPEAKER: My question is, so knowing
now that people grow up in the type of literacy,
whether it's traditional or emancipatory,
what are the pros and cons of your type of
literacy?
And explain why we should move ether towards
or away from an emancipatory literacy.
AUDIENCE: I think you all gave some really
great points towards moving to emancipatory
literacy.
I mean, if it's helping people learn, I don't
see a down fall, especially because it's kind
of broadening their world view.
A couple of presentations ago, there were
other students who were playing jeopardy with
AAE, and that was kind of like broadening
their worldview.
Like even if you went to the school and didn't
speak AAE you were learning about a new language
that you weren't familiar with.
And so they were able to do this through the
emancipatory sort literacy.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: What's AAE?
AUDIENCE: Oh, African American English.
Sorry. Not AAPE.
AUDIENCE: So kind of just playing devil's
advocate a little bit, I think-- I guess one
of the dangers of emancipatory literacy might
be kind of this non-standardization like with
issues like Common Core and things like that.
We kind of have an educational system that's
set up so that everybody's kind of put on
the same level, to some extent.
Like everybody has that same kind of baseline
education.
But like with emancipatory literacy, I think
you're going to find educational programs
are more geared towards a specific like cultural
norms and things of that nature related to
whatever population it targets.
So I wonder if that could potentially produce
a system in which certain students, even though
they're receiving an education that is geared
towards them, it's objectively not that same
quality of student who are receiving more
of a traditional literacy approach.
I'm just putting it out there.
GUEST SPEAKER: I want to push back on that
just a little bit, because I think that the
standardized approach to education is the
approach that's been taken with, you know,
teach for a test approach, and it's failed.
It's been failing for a while now, and I think
that a lot of people in education policy and
even just teachers are recognizing that now.
And I think that education-- emancipatory
literacy gives us an interesting lens to think
about how to educate people so that they can
learn.
And I think maybe another place you can start
kind of investing energy is thinking of ways
in society that we can value those different
ways of knowing and being and learning, so
that it's not just, you went to college, so
you deserve to be paid a lot of money kind
of thing, and it's a, oh you can build a table
from scratch.
How do you get paid to do that?
AUDIENCE: Where do you think MIT falls on
the spectrum of like emancipatory literacy?
[laughing]
GUEST SPEAKER: I think MIT is way far on the
tradition.
MIT is the Alt right of traditional literacy,
I think.
[laughing] I just think that there are-- I
think that the immense pressure that falls
on students, just on students physical bodies,
is definitely a symptom of a larger problem.
And for me, the fact that that symptom is
not enough of an impetus to change, is heartbreaking.
Because I think that-- I didn't come to college
expecting it to be the best four years of
my life, but I didn't come here also expecting
to just suffer.
[laughing] And so I think that there's definitely
got to be a way where I can bloom, can reach
my best potential.
And I love learning.
I love-- like I love school, you know, and
the fact that I have just kept running up
against the institution, I think, as a creative
person, has made me kind of step back and
think again about emancipatory literacy and
how I can do that after.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: So I have a question for you,
Cynthia.
So given what you just said, how would you--
so if you were to be MIT's president, what
would you change?
What-- how would you make it better more emancipatory?
Keeping in mind that there are certain goals
that you have to reach in terms of, say, chemical
engineering, if you're a chemist, how would
you do that?
How would you advise administration be better
on that score?
CYNTHIA: I think very first thing I would
do is have people who are more interested
in research not be professors.
So the ones who are interested in research
should be doing research full time, and the
people who are interested in teaching should
teach.
Because I think that that gives like-- that
gives people more impetus just to connect
with their students and actually get to know
them, and I think in that kind of environment,
you would foster like a safer, healthier environment
for learning.
Whereas if you have a professor who is more
interested in winning the Nobel Prize, like
what are you-- what do you do coming up against
that?
I also would have MIT think very, very hard
about where the funding is coming from?
What it's going to?
And how that kind of fits in the global system,
where MIT as an institution fits into the
global system, as kind of not only an institution
that does propel you to a higher class, but
kind of does that at the expense of a lot
of other people and systems across the globe
even if it's not directly in the area.
So I think that being more critical and intentional
about our values, and also maybe adding soul
to the end of that-- end of the that motto.
But--
MICHEL DEGRAFF: OK, OK.
CYNTHIA: Yeah.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Thank you. I think we
should move to the third question.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: The last question is, from your
personal experiences, or what you've seen
or read about, how do you think we can improve
students' experiences and confidence through
intentional language use in schools?
Like what mottoes do you think are working,
or would work?
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Go ahead Colin.
AUDIENCE: So bouncing of that it seems we
get to [inaudible] thing where it [inaudible]
is inculcated in this standard curriculum.
It goes into society and then perpetuates
the standard curriculum back on the Indian
students.
So I'm curious about if anyone has thoughts
how you could make knowledge about-- because
one of the main hurdles is people instituting,
or interrogating the standard curriculum is
just strictly about how the story of America's
history has been with regarding the Native
American genocide, slavery, and, for lack
of a better word, mean that it is manifest destiny.
How do you make people aware of that on a
level that they can see those things playing
out today, then work to interrogate that curriculum?
Especially if they are coming from a background
where race isn't talked about in this family
because it's an uncomfortable topic, or if
they just haven't heard about these things
necessarily because of school.
AUDIENCE: For me, I feel like it's more about
where do you learn to interrogate your own
beliefs, and I feel like that's hard to find.
And I came to-- this class was a huge part
of that for me.
And I don't know if that because I started
out, or if I just happened to stumble upon
a place where I learned to interrogate my
own beliefs.
But I think this isn't a point to make for
themselves, but I don't really have an answer
for how we get triple the value in evaluating
in interrogating your own beliefs, or how
much more in [inaudible] learn to interrogate
your own beliefs before attacking someone else's.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, bouncing off of I think a
common theme that we come up in this class
is how do we have conversations with people
who don't want to these conversations?
And I think the only way for them to figure
it out is for them to interrogate themselves,
but most of those people won't.
So finding ways to make them interrogate themselves,
I think is gonna be a common problem throughout
history.
And unfortunately I don't know I, personally,
have a great solution for that.
But I think more opportunities like this--
I mean obviously you mentioned this before,
the people who are taking this class, were
not really diversified at all right?
We all sought this class out mostly, so I
don't know how you can get someone who doesn't
want interrogate themselves in to a situation
like this.
So maybe mandating something like this where
you have to go a black history class, or a
Native American history class, or whatever
might force people to start talking about
it.
The history will speak for itself.
I think that history is-- if you know the
full history of the United States for example--
it's pretty terrible and I think that you
do need to know the whole history, and also
need to get the alternative sides and have
those be integrated into the curriculum.
I also was interested in thinking about entry
points into these conversations, and ways
that our humor can function as entry points
in these conversations.
I've been having this conversation with a
friend of mine of how humor, for example,
gives us a way to kind of express some of
these things that are more taboo, and kind
of laugh them off, and kind of integrate them,
as opposed to everyone shunning them and people
feeling bottled.
So I am interested about humor and art specifically
as entry point into these conversations.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: [inaudible].
So Dana, I think what you say in a way answers
the concern that Shope expressed right?
Because Shope put it as dual choice.
That you either do this or you do that, right?
So Dana is right, right Shope,?
One can imagine having in the class-- the
principle math class, chemistry class-- paying
attention to those issues.
In fact there room for that, even if you take
a simple photography class one can even think
about what kind of choices go into making
your camera?
And actually, I have friends who are photographers
and they explain to me that actually most
cameras were not geared to take pictures of
black people.
So even as a white photographer he finds that
when he takes a picture with his regular Cannon
of a white person it comes much better than
when takes it of a black person.
Why? Because the lenses are designed with a
normal gaze of the white subject right?
So he had to tweak his camera to make it take
good pictures of black people.
So even there, even in physics there's a way
to interrogate the curriculum.
Why selections are made with the lens for
example?
So in a way it could both, you could both
have the necessary interest in human beings
the quote unquote more "traditional curriculum".
And going back to the other point, can you
imagine also in history, in biology, biology
could include text like I mentioned earlier,
The Mismeasure of Man if you wish, goes into
lots of integral issues about biology.
About how we make-- heads were measured to
show that humans are as intelligent.
At Harvard for example, for many years when
you were coming in you had to undress and
they took your picture naked, and they would
at your picture to decide what kind of students
you would become based on physical traits,
like because your head.
This was Harvard.
I guess this was one proponent of what was
called then phrenology.
Which is the measure of--
So there is plenty, plenty of room to integrate
those kind intricacies within traditional
curriculum.
OK, so thank you very much.
[applause]